okay so on my channel I usually talk
about making lots of money having a huge
impact change in the world doing things
you believe in
you know massive big growth but today's
good is a little bit different today I
want to talk about getting to five
figures and I'm gonna show you five ways
to go from dead broke to five figures in
five months and why five figures for me
five figures is a really important mark
because it shows you that what you're
doing is important and has ability to
grow at the early fight figures you know
the ten thousand dollars if you're
making ten thousand dollars with your
business hey that's not a lot but it's
still ten thousand dollars you know
that's nothing to sneeze at that's a
good part-time income that's something
that you can invest back into your
business and and put a little bit into
your life and start living a little bit
better lifestyle and it's choosing
people willing to buy what you're
selling the high five figures now if you
get into like the ninety thousand dollar
range hey that might be time I'm
quitting my job right I'm hiring people
I'm expanding I'm growing this thing I'm
ready to bust through and so getting to
five figures is an awesome platform to
then be able to help you leverage that
to grow and a lot of people can't get to
that level so this video is about how to
get to five figures in five months ready
for the tips here we go number one is
get a customer most people when they
have an idea they start work on their
idea right you start working you're
tinkering you're creating your product
to come with your your service idea your
you're at home you're writing your
business plan you're you're making Excel
spreadsheets you're you're building your
prototypes but you never actually go out
and start talking to customers and this
is a mistake that so many entrepreneurs
make you've got to talk to customers
first reverse that whole process start
by talking to potential customers call
them up have a coffee with them ask
through their advice their input you're
not selling anything yet you want people
to say wow that's really cool if you can
build that if you could do this for me
I'd be willing to pay you for it and
this was me I remember when I was
starting my first business I was dead
broke dead broke three
two dollars a month beans for lunch
everyday can't afford anything can't
afford be with my friends nothing
feeling like crap
and I was that guy who was sitting there
working on my product and working on my
plan and working on the perfect pitch
and spending months doing that and never
actually talking to customers and the
growth came when I started going out and
talking to them I figured out that you
know what my whole plan is wrong my
assumptions were wrong what I thought
would work is not gonna work we gotta
change everything around once I started
talking to customers so that's how you
want to start before you quit your job
before you start investing money into
something start talking to customers get
their feedback get their opinions their
advice their help get them to say I
would buy that if you had that available
get both three orders and then go launch
the business around specific customer
needs so number one is get a customer
number two is network with influencers
you want to start to understand the
industry that you're getting into and
start making connections with people who
can potentially help you out so whatever
business are getting into if you have no
idea what it's all about you should
start to learn right now hopefully
there's something within your job that
you might be able to expand your scope
you know if you need to learn how to how
to write copy better you need to learn
how to meet certain suppliers maybe
there's a way to do it through your job
and be creative and talk to your your
boss and see if there's any way you can
get into this project even it's for free
because that's gonna help you learn and
make connections but otherwise it may
mean you go and you moonlight and you
volunteer for certain companies just to
learn because you want to make contacts
you want to know who the customers are
who the suppliers are how the industry
works so that when you start and when
you're running your business yourself
you're not making all the mistakes
ideally you get paid to make mistakes
right you have a job that you're
learning from not just making money from
but you want to start to get known
within the industry you want to be able
to pick up the phone to somebody who's
important in that industry and they know
who you are so you have to start getting
those connections you have to start
going to trade shows you have to start
working with suppliers you have to start
making those key connections that might
be as simple as calling somebody up or
we're tweeting them and saying I'm
getting certain this business I love if
you have 15 minutes for a quick coffee
as a quick mentorship I want to ask you
a couple questions pick your brain I'll
show up wherever you are and I'm buying
coffee it's on me if you could please
help out a new struggling entrepreneur
I'd really appreciate the feedback
something like just to get on the map to
start getting to know these people so
that they would recognize your name and
could be great resources for you to
introduce you to customers so number two
is network with influencers number three
is tell your story this is a big thing
that a lot of entrepreneurs miss people
like buying from people and so you want
to tell your story right tell me why
you're passionate about this tell me why
you've started this business tell me
what you're hoping to accomplish with it
tell me how you went through these
struggles and came to this solution
right if I'm talking about entrepreneurs
and I tell the story about how I know
I'm an entrepreneur and I struggle with
my first business and I almost went
broke and I told my business partner I
quit and I was making nothing and then
how I turned it around telling a
personal story connects you to me better
and it makes it easier for you to digest
information I'm giving you more likely
to want to work with me because I'm
showing the human side of it and that's
your big in as an entrepreneur is that
you can tell your story where most
corporations the guys you might be going
up against in your market they suck at
telling their story it's so impersonal
nobody likes buying from a company so
tell me your story put your picture up
on your website if it's on your business
card tell me why you're doing this let
me feel some passion out of it make a
video if you want write your text on
your website write that tell me why this
is important to you what you're trying
to accomplish because if I can feel
connected to that story of yours I'm
much more likely to want to buy from you
to buy more from you to refer my friends
to you to write about you to introduce
you to people make me feel something
tell your story
number four is partner up find people
who are already selling to your target
audience and find a way to partner up
with them so that everybody that they
introduce you to and they make a sale
from you get a commission so they have
an incentive to want to do it this is
what saved my business my first company
when I was dead broke making $300 a
month couldn't survive this is what
saved it I started
Microsoft success and was through
partnerships and I started reaching out
to companies who were selling to my
audience my onus was scientists and I
found all these companies who are
selling the scientists and said hey I
have a product scientists love it you
guys can make some extra money selling
it to and some of the companies I
remember this one company my first deal
I managed to to get an exclusive
arrangement with them so that they would
be the only one selling our software in
a certain country and I negotiate an
upfront payment from them and they had
they paid me thirteen and a half
thousand dollars for that and for a guy
making three hundred dollars a month
thirteen and a half thousand dollars up
front was was life-changing that was a
huge amount of money right there I went
from making nothing to five figures and
more importantly it gave me a strategy
to continue to expand and I sold another
distribution another distribution
another distribution so whatever product
or service you're selling make a list of
all the different people who have access
to your customers that are not direct
competitors to you and find a way to
reach out to them introduce what you're
doing and give them an incentive and a
reason to want to promote you so that
everybody wins so number four is partner
and number five is used the media it's
never been so easy to get your story out
there right we backed up to number three
is tell your story now use your media to
get that story out there with my
software company the first one what
really helped was I was positioning
ourselves as experts in the industry and
anytime there was something that came
out that was related to our business I
sent out a press release and I used our
founder who was a scientist as as the
expert and got him quoted and got him
featured and anytime he got picked up in
a major publication it led to sales for
us right if you think about advertising
in a magazine or on a website it's
expensive and people there they're bored
of it right how often you pay attention
to advertising and as an entrepreneur
just starting up you can't afford that
but how about a story when you read a
magazine what are you looking at you
looking at the stories when you go to a
blog what are you looking at you looking
at the stories right so to get featured
in those stories could be gold free
people are reading those publications
they're looking for information they see
you as an expert who solved the problem
and they are likely to want to visit
your website and buy whatever product
the service is selling so what I would
do is at the start and this is for my
business - when I launched at McCarran
TOCOM was I made a list of all the
reporters who covered my industry and
every two weeks I would send out a press
release and the press release wasn't the
boring self-serving promotional crap
that most people do in a press release I
would write a press release like it was
a story like it was something that they
could just copy and paste and put onto
their website in their blog in their
newspaper and some people did and then
even let me know and it's Naugle news
alert saying I was featured in whatever
a newspaper and was just a direct copy
and paste of what I sent them with every
story remember there's an expert right
there's somebody who's quoted when
they're showing facts and figures and
talking about some news story
there's always an expert that expert
should be you right you should know your
industry you should be one of the best
in the world at what you do and you
should be featured as an expert and you
are making the jobs of the reporters so
much easier because they always need
experts to reach out to and knowing that
someone reliable who knows what they're
talking about who will respond quickly
to phone calls and emails makes it
easier them to reach out to you on every
story that comes across their desk so
you start by making your own list by
sending out those press releases every
two weeks and then by being accessible
and available to reporters for future
interviews use the media so in some way
the five ways to go from dead broke the
five figures and five months number one
get a customer number to network with
influencers number three tell your story
number four partner up number five use
the media and believe for those who are
watching like this video subscribe to
see more like it if you have tips on how
you got to five figures leave it in the
comments below so others can learn from
it as well thank you guys so much for
watching I'll see you soon
hi every kill English here with mermaid
junkie TV are you on evans newsletter
subscription if not you should be I read
every single one and you should too
channel
you